ici ça nous fait salle à manger le soir
on tire la banquette ça nous fait
chambre à coucher
c'est vraiment bien la caravane une
petite maison sur roues qui a
révolutionné les vacances mais depuis sa
démocratisation dans les années 60
qu'elle place occupe-t-elle en somme
c'est la bonne vie oui voyez-vous
rigides pliables métal plastique
il y à des caravanes pour tous les
budgets qu'est ce qui vous a fait passer
de l'année camping à la caravane parfois
le confort de confort plus grands un
phénomène de société
en 1971 52 mille véhicules neufs sont
immatriculés je crois que je vais me
décider pour acheter une caravane et ça
grince ça grimpe jusqu'à frôler les
90000 nouvelles immatriculations en 1980
à votre santé et votre sens cher mais
les années qui suivent la caravane ne
fait plus rêver
entre 1980 et 2010 est le marché du neuf
a été divisée par rose
mais alors que s'est-il passé on est
bien sûr une mauvaise route là tu t'es
trompé que je crois que tu te faire faut
faire demi tour
la caravane s'est fait dépasser par plus
moderne
le camping car alors que les ventes de
caravanes chute depuis les années 80 le
camping-car cdu de plus en plus depuis
vingt huit véhicules neufs sont
immatriculés chaque année le camping
paperasse passé s'est passé s'est passé
mais n'enterrons pas la caravane trop
vite les neuf font moins recette mais le
marché de l'occasion est florissant
d'ailleurs en 2018 le parc français de
caravane compte 518 1891 véhicules pas
encore rattrapé par les camping cars
[Musique]
ici